okay next Franklin I'm on my way
finishing to set up a food business with
the twist the concept is created
originally by me the problem is i need
to make myself believe more so kind of
related question there that it will work
no matter what and I seek for more
entrepreneurial guides so know exactly
what the food is with food food business
with the twist and he doesn't believe in
the concept no matter what what kind of
advice would you give Franklin on that
well frankly I guess you've got to
believe in the idea and if you believe
in the product in the food business I
think then you've got to find you know
how do you go about the distribution
channel but I do believe in food there's
so much kind of changing food with
organic with vegan with all the
different diets that people were
adopting around the world around healthy
lifestyle it's a golden time to be
innovative in the food business there's
such an opportunity out there and again
you know I think we as a company have a
policy of buying from small and medium
businesses and we back from startups so
loads of people would say you know I
couldn't go and call in a big company
but we we send the guys down here to get
lunches just from the market stalls
downstairs and see kind of you go
against stop all those voices in your
head so he can't bc that's the key thing
is you have to believe in the idea and
again I you know the pre crazy dumper an
11 year old micaela our ulmer was
literally bitten by bees when she was
having four and her story is you know
very personal that gave her the idea of
actually through a whole series of event
of creating a product called let around
lemonade and she eventually sold that
animal 2 million pound deal to
multi-million dollar deal to whole foods
so and it just came through a number of
elements that are totally unconnected
but it gave her a really great idea that
she really believed in and then she did
a multi-million deal as a result of that
and obviously you know the rest is
history to expand on that I'd love to
see you test it you know Tessa on a
small scale see what's working if you
get some early wins like Stephen said
you sell your first one it's easy to
believe in the second
the third one the fourth one and I think
too many times people make it's such a
big idea that they can't take the first
step without a ton of money or without a
ton of you know roadblocks in front of
them and so your foot concept with the
twist I've been looking at how can I
just start making some sales of this how
can I start getting some momentum of
this and as you start seeing people
eating it and tasting it and liking it
and spreading the word if it's much
easier to keep going and get some
momentum and continue to believe in
yourself so just have the big dream but
start small yeah and the other thing I
would you know today pop-up stores are
there for food they're everywhere you
know you don't have to buy real estate
you can do things exactly as you say
start small kind of mentally treat treat
everything you're doing very carefully
around your money because it's very
scarce to almost running on fumes but
then think how do i get market-tested
how do i find out what audience is like
what is the consumer there's going to be
really interested in my big idea and and
if you go on a movie night or something
and set up a pop-up door outside of
movie theater that's a great way to go
and then you'll find out you know just
judge your product appeal to the older
generation to the healthy generation you
know should you set up outside of
geminal and still there's loads of
things you can do but I'd say constantly
innovate to Evans point change and cause
correct according to what works and
double down on what works and once
you've got your idea kind of fully
worked out then think how do you scale
out